géant gastambide est avec le chocolat
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'il est beau bassin
je suis très heureux de te dirai ce vol
semer pour les vainqueurs des six est il
n'est pas sûr il sait pas il devait me
retourne et je pense retourner merci
merci d'être là pour cette première
merci non mais surtout merci non mais ça
va leur révéler comment s'effectue la
met bas parce que par rapport aux
assedic
voilà tu vois tu sais que c'est un peu
flippant de faire la première banon ont
fait la première et la dernière en même
temps d'en dire non mais je ne pensais
pas que ça allait moins angoissé comme
ça mais je suis angoissé puisque alors
il ya des telles que je connais là mais
il ya plein de gens qu'on connaît pas on
se passe ils sont gentils ou pas on va
pas se fier dans les bottes lors on a
passé des vacances ensemble
vous avez bien rigolé raconté un jour
elle été pendant très longtemps au
téléphone et ça m'a agacé
voilà qui je l'attendais parce que voilà
je voulais jouer avec lui au tournant
final innotour faire des acquis et faire
du tir à l'arc et jambes et en guise de
punition mais franchement alors je vous
dis je t'ai avec malik bentalha et on
s'impatiente et la maîtrise et on s'est
dit qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on
s'impatiente je me suis senti obligé
pour le pour le presser de franck qu'est
ce qui s'est passé alors la personne est
si présent a décidé en guise de
protestation de déféquer dans mes
baskets
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est quand même une des plus
grosses barres de rire de notre vie de
notre vie franchement qu'est la le futon
parterre de rett a les jambes coupées
des pirates allemands fou sa tête a même
dû t'en as tu vois que tu dis mais il a
vraiment fait ça mais comment je vais
rentrer chez moi mais j'ai plus de
regrets quand même parce que j'aimerais
savoir le procès comme on commence le
procédé à la sculpter par shotwell et
attends tu vas comprendre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis au téléphone
je le fais on retrouve juste après